I don't think I ever felt at home before
cancer brilliant
I don't think quite easily felt out of
place in Israel if you asked me where my
home is then I will say brilliant
because I feel I belong here
God then Moshe was born in 1985 in Tel
Aviv his parents divorced when he was 15
in the same year he began working in a
fish factory and soon decided he'd like
to train as a chef Gavan Moshe worked in
Tel Aviv London and Chicago before
moving to Berlin in 2012 with a view to
opening his own restaurant my life
revolved there our food since I remember
myself my mom has like the funniest
stories about me being three year old
and ordering a shrimps field for real in
a restaurant with almond sauce
ya know kids meal for me or sitting with
a breakfast table eating the cereals
with cook books like looking at the
pictures anything and when I basically
started reading I already started
cooking
berlin's Charlottenburg district is an
affluent residential neighborhood home
to lots of celebrities politicians and
diplomats
[Music]
galvan moshus restaurant is in a side
street on the ground floor of an
apartment block from the 1970s the
premises used to house a gym glass
opened in 2013
gaba moshe came up with the interior
design himself he wanted to give his
eatery the feel of a modern bistro
[Music]
the kitchen is behind a mirrored screen
[Music]
turbot with freekeh is one of the
restaurants signature dishes Israel is a
country with many different cultures
Jewish Muslim Christian Arab African
immigrants from Eastern Europe and the
US also lived there this diversity is
reflected in the cuisine
Israeli cuisine is a mixture of
Mediterranean European North American
and local Arab influences
[Music]
freekeh is a cereal made from green
durum wheat
it contains plenty of minerals so it's
considered to be very healthy Ricky is a
Palestinian weight that is harvested a
bit early and in order to get it to a
ripened condition where you can eat it
and cook it she it's basically roasted
on an open flame on charcoals giving it
um
it's green because it's a bit unripe and
it gets the smokiness from the charcoal
this is something a bit different in
flavor garden Moshe likes to experiment
he's a sort of culinary artist who likes
to create new and unusual dishes
mushrooms herbs and smoke mixed in a jar
he calls this dish and forest in a glass
he got the idea while walking through
the woods
[Music]
gobby moshe gets his inspiration
wherever he can
he sees himself as a chef who blends the
modern with the traditional food is very
central in Israel we surround ourselves
with food and rest Johnson and eating
out and cold and and I think it's a very
important cultural thing probably the
favorite form of entertainment at glass
there is no a la carte instead diners
get to choose from two menus one with
five courses the other with seven guy
ben-moshe creates a new menu every month
and serves up his culinary delights five
days a week
[Music]
to boot in covet Bama freaky Berg Venuto
but Evan
[Music]